with less than three weeks to go till
the election
many americans are eager to learn about
the candidates
so it is imperative that our information
channels are open and
americans can access stories by the
press
and from their own social circles
congress believed in this power of
information so much they created special
liability protections
for information platforms such as
technology companies like
facebook twitter and google it is called
section 230 and i have believed in the
principles outlined in the law
but it is clear that section 230 in its
current form
is no longer working
just last week justice clarence thomas
said the courts have read sweeping new
protections into 230
that congress never put into statute it
is time to scrap the law
and start over yesterday the new york
post one of the country's largest
newspapers
published a piece on hunter biden and
his work on the board of ukrainian
energy company burisma which he had no
qualifications for it is an important
story as most americans would be
appalled by the vice president's son
using his father's position
to earn an enormous contract from
foreign companies
but the response from many in the media
and twitter and facebook
bring to light an even bigger concern
the biggest social networks are
selectively censoring information
if you are a citizen and posted
information in the story
your account was locked last night the
republican house judiciary committee
posted the story on their website a
government
website and this morning twitter has
censored it
did big tech censor the media and
americans when they posted about the
unverified
and later debunked still dossier did big
tech
censor the media and americans when they
posted about trump's taxes
which were of course obtained illegally
did big tech censor the world's largest
sponsor of terrorism
the supreme leader of iran the answer to
all three questions is no
if social media companies intend to use
the protections provided by congress
for some americans but not for others we
should remove those special standards
all together now ranking member jim
jordan and the house judiciary committee
have legislation
that should be voted on to restore free
expression
in americans town squares
republicans are clear on what we need to
do to serve the american public
republicans are part of our commitment
to america have been
clear how we would restore our way of
life rebuild
the economy and renew the american dream
chief among our goals is keeping small
businesses open
and the employees on payroll i know what
it's like to have a dream
i know what it's like to have a dream to
have a small business
in fact we have been relentless in our
push to get speaker pelosi
to provide needed relief for americans
she continues to turn her back
and focus on politics not people
81 days ago when speaker pelosi was
asked if the house will stay in session
until a deal is negotiated she answered
we can't go home without it
a few days later she sent us home for
the august recess with no deal
republicans have attempted to bring up
small business committee ranking member
steve shabbat's legislation
to reopen paycheck protection to support
small businesses
and their employees but democrats have
blocked
any ppp money going forward
39 times that's 39 times we brought it
to the floor that they have voted no on
it
speaker pelosi does not want to lift a
finger to help the american people
because she believes in her own words
and let me quote
that nothing is better than something
and negotiations
are all about leverage it is clear
she has offered resistance instead of
relief
and she has wasted precious time this
year
eating ice cream in front of a
refrigerator blaming a salon owner for
her special treatment
and now insulting wolf blitzer these are
not
actions of a functioning democratic
majority
with that i'll take questions
yes sir um the president keeps talking
about that he would like to see congress
go big or go home on a
coven relief bill i think the
administration's offer is somewhere
around 1.8 trillion right now he's
talked about going even higher than that
would house republicans support a 1.8
trillion or
bigger deal if that's reached between
the speaker and the white house
you know what's most interesting here is
the president 1.8 is a
very big deal a large that that's a big
deal
but unfortunately nancy pelosi still
makes us go home instead of
getting something done i think the
american people would want anything
to have to go forward republicans have
time and again
pushed forwards ideas forward
unfortunately the speaker controls the
house
so the answer to your question it
doesn't matter what our answer would be
because the speaker has denied anything
for moving even her own
members to vote for a 1.8 trillion or
you know i would always
i'd always read a bill before i
encourage anybody to vote for anything
but what's interesting to me is her
own members the democrats have asked her
to take this deal
she is the only hurdle the only
roadblock
to us even being able to vote on
something we have a discharge petition
that would remove ppp money that's
sitting there 137 billion dollars
she has forced her members not to sign
there is one stumbling block to any deal
getting through it doesn't matter the
size
the speaker of the house is the only one
that's denying it
yes do you have any like what's your do
you believe that there will be a coveted
relief deal i know we keep asking this
question but will there be a covered
relief deal for the american people
before the election as long as speaker
pelosi is involved i think the answer is
easily no
you've watched her every single time
we've tried to have coveted relief she's
always held the process up
now she's strangling the american public
by denying anything moving
he watched even her arguing with wolf
blitzer
because he wanted to read quotes from
her own members
asking her to take the deal
i think she cares more about politics
than she cares about the american public
it's obvious
with her actions remember why she said
she doesn't want to go forward
she is fearful the american public would
get a check
fearful that the president would get
some credit instead of helping the
american public in this time of need
yes i just have a quick question
regarding um cloven 19.
if the deal if a deal is um approved on
a bill goes to the center and your
members
have to come back what is your plan to
keep your members and their staff safe
from the coronavirus
well that's a great question you'll know
about four or five months ago
i put a report out along with rodney
davis and tom cole on how we could keep
the house safe
one of the elements was testing
unfortunately speaker pelosi has denied
that the protections on which committees
we'd bring back the size of staff in
which we'd bring back
unfortunately speaker pelosi has denied
all the abilities where we worked with a
lot of the medical community
to come with a plan to keep the house
safe one of those would be testing
thank you so very much have a good day
so
uh
[Music]
so
hmm real quick
oh
[Laughter]
six
[Music]
ten ten
uh
and
uh
uh